[Music]
world war ii has countless stories of
bravery sacrifice camaraderie and
heroism but the war also has a lot of
mysteries many of them still unsolved
like the legend of the phantom fortress
a b-17 bomber that returned from a
mission with no crew aboard and somehow
landed itself
let's find out why
[Music]
the first thing they heard was the
distant roar of the plane's engines i
can't hear those fighter planes
and i can hear those fighter planes
why a youtube sunday bloody sunday i
know the song can you at least let me
get into the story
[Music]
okay okay i'm sorry good go ahead with
there what do you think thank you but
i'm right here if you need me
the first thing they heard was the
distant roar of the plane's engines on
november 23rd 1944 the ground crew at
the royal air force base in kortenberg
belgium looked to the sky if the sound
wasn't a giveaway the distinctive
silhouette was this was a b-17 a massive
35 thousand pound u.s army bomber called
the flying fortress and this fortress
was headed right for them rapidly there
was no landing schedule that day so the
ground personnel assumed this was an
emergency it was coming in at very high
speed flying erratically and had its
landing gear down and as the bomber got
closer the soldiers started to panic the
plane was dropping so fast that it
looked like 18 tons of steel fuel and
explosives were gonna crash right into
them the soldiers hit the deck as the
bomber barely cleared the anti-aircraft
guns then they felt the earth shake as
the b-17 crashed into the ground still
moving at high speed the plane tore
through a field the landing was so
violent that pieces of propeller broke
off and shot through the air the wings
were crushed on impact still intact but
badly damaged the plane finally dragged
to a stop
three out of its four engines were still
running the men on the ground waited
expecting the bomber's crew or at least
some of the crew to emerge
they didn't soldiers on the ground
waited nervously for 15 minutes while
the plane's engines continued to run
nobody came out at this point the men on
the ground were getting suspicious they
were worried this was a trap
finally after 20 minutes of watching and
waiting major john crisp slowly
approached the plane major crisp drew
his sidearm opened the hatch and climbed
in he expected to see men dead or dying
but the plane was completely empty
he wrote down what he found we now made
a thorough search and our most
remarkable find in the fuselage was
about a dozen parachutes neatly wrapped
and ready for clipping on this made the
whereabouts of the crew even more
mysterious back on the navigator's desk
was the code book giving the colours and
letters of the day for identification
purposes various furlined flying jackets
lay in the fuselage together with a few
bars of chocolate partly consumed in
some cases aside from what was sustained
from a hard landing the plane had no
damage the parachutes were still there
so the crew couldn't have bailed out
food was left half-eaten it was like
they just vanished
major crisp shut down the engines and
looked for signs trying to piece
together what happened he found the
plane's logbook the final entry
ominously read
bad flak
major crisp climbed out of the plane and
signaled to his men that it was all
clear there was nobody on board the
soldiers asked how could this be
the major shrugged and said
the plane landed itself
so now there are two big questions first
what happened to the men on board and
second how did this plane fly maneuver
and land without them the press called
the plane the phantom fortress and the
ghost ship and the story was published
in stars and stripes and became an
instant legend
investigators identified the b-17 as
part of the 91st bomber group out of
east anglia england the base had records
that the plane had taken off with a full
crew there was plenty of evidence that
they were on board but now they were
nowhere to be found now that the army
had the names of the men calls went out
to every base and post in the area after
a few days all 10 men were found in
perfect health they were at a nearby air
base in belgium lieutenant harold r de
bolt was the pilot and explained what
happened his b-17 was flying a mission
over mursburg germany bombing oil
refineries and mersburg dreaded mursburg
as it came to be known had twice as many
anti-aircraft guns as berlin almost 160
b-17s were shot down over the city so
these were dangerous skies
as the bomber group climbed to 28 000
feet to begin its run the bolt noticed
he had a malfunction in one of his
engines and couldn't make it to bombing
altitude then another malfunction forced
the plane off course
now drifting away from its bomber group
the bolt's b17 was vulnerable the bomber
drifted into german anti-aircraft fire
and was taking a lot of damage both from
the ground and from fighters in the air
the plane quickly filled up with smoke
and fire the bolt attempted to drop his
ordinance but the bomb rack was jammed
then the plane took another hit on its
bombay door the bolt said it was a
miracle that every bomb on board didn't
explode another engine took so much
damage from any aircraft fire that it
practically sheared off from the plane
the weather was bad and with only two
working engines devolt pulled out and
turned back to england the bomber badly
damaged kept losing altitude de bolt
knew they were in trouble he ordered the
crew to throw everything overboard
hoping to lighten the plane it didn't
help it kept falling at this point it
was clear that the bomber was not gonna
make it all the way across the english
channel not with only two engines so de
bolt ordered the crew to ditch and the
men parachuted safely behind allied
lines in belgium the last thing he saw
was his bomber flying into heavy fog he
figured it would crash a few minutes
later
it didn't the bolt's plane continued to
fly for miles and finally made a rough
but relatively clean landing at an
allied airfield in belgium investigators
were now left with a puzzle the bolt
said he lost two engines and the plane
was severely damaged but eyewitnesses
like major crisp said three engines were
working and the plane had no damage at
all and all parachutes were accounted
for investigators said they probably had
extra parachutes on board and the third
engine could have come back on by itself
and the plane landing in an allied
airfield was just a coincidence it was
good luck
this explanation was enough to satisfy
investigators and the case was closed
luck a plane flies itself back home and
lands on its own and it's luck that's
the report i don't buy it well
eyewitnesses didn't buy it either they
felt that something supernatural had
taken place
and the legend of the phantom fortress
was born
[Music]
i had never heard of the phantom
fortress before this topic like most
topics i cover was submitted by you so
if there's a story you'd like to see and
see us get to the bottom of go to the
y-files.com tips i can't do every story
but i read every message so the phantom
fortress is it true yes and no this
legend is actually two stories that got
mixed together in 1943 a b-17 crashed
near the home of a young boy named john
gell in england and gail and his family
saw the bomber flying toward their
village engines sputtering and that
plane crashed into an outcropping of
trees near the boy's home when john
gill's father rushed to help the crew he
found nobody on board and about 40 years
later john gill was relaying the story
that he saw a bomber maneuvering with
its squadron flying in formation
but it eventually crashed and when they
searched the plane it was empty they
later learned that the crew had
parachuted behind enemy lines fought
their way out of germany and were back
in another b-17 soon after this didn't
happen most likely john gell heard the
story of the phantom fortress and pulled
some of the details into his story and
then as every good storyteller does
added his own flair and tell the story
enough times your brain can actually
form memories to reinforce that story
the b-17 that crashed near gel's home
was actually the cata9 tails the plane
took a lot of damage over germany but
made it back across the channel quickly
running out of fuel the crew bailed out
over john gale's village and in 1944 a
british anti-aircraft crew saw a b-17
make a hard landing in a nearby field
one of the plane's wings hit first
causing it to spin around and major john
crisp was indeed the officer who
searched the plane and found it empty
this was the bomber flown by de bolt's
crew
but how does a plane land itself well
before jumping out de bolt had engaged
the autopilot which is protocol when
ditching the plane was moving slowly and
descending and the autopilot kept it
level it finally came down in an open
field near an anti-aircraft installation
but not on an air base it could have
easily crashed in the sea in the woods
or in a village like the other b-17 and
this type of thing happened all the time
but this plane happened to come down in
a field the other aspects of the story
like the half-eaten chocolate bars and
the parachutes being intact were added
to the story later in legends like
roanoke island or the mary celeste
tables are set for dinner and food is
left half-eaten this really ups the
creepy factor so i can understand why
these details were eventually added
besides nobody eats half a chocolate bar
that's true we know what really happened
because there are detailed records of
these planes their crews and their
missions and i'll link to them below if
you want to learn more the legend of the
phantom fortress while a great ghost
story is just a story but let's be
honest
even without the supernatural aspect
what actually happened that a massive
b-17 landed gently on its own is still
amazing and because it's true
i think it makes the story better
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share i know
i sound like a broken record but it
really helps the channel and special
thanks to our generous patrons who make
this channel possible that's gonna do it
until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you